this is Startalk there is convergence
intersection between those who claim the
earth is 6,000 years old and those who
deny climate climate change it is Ken
Ham is explicit that the earth is
getting cooler it's not warming he's
just wrong I mean and it wouldn't matter
except so in the Venn diagram these two
are overlapping sharpie a black sharpie
where they intersect you can see it from
across the room or at your section yeah
well you know it's a isn't it it's
probably because there is even if let's
say the earth was heating up and we are
all headed towards imminent disaster it
does make a difference imminent imminent
the three said eminent no imminent
disaster it has in very soon coming with
great urgency ah we it does not make a
difference because one day there will be
a new heaven and a new earth so who
cares about this place yeah so so when
we do about that bill with the longest
journey starts with a bit of single step
so people listen to the show for example
right these are scientifically literate
people people want to know more about
science I strongly believe that in the
next few years we're going to reach a
tipping point but it is going to be as
we say in sailboat racing a near run
thing I say that all the time when I
race myself yeah it's gonna be a close
call that cuz that makes it so much
clearer to me what you're saying it's
good it's called your run thing it's not
gonna be it's not clear who's going to
get to the buoy first the climate change
that undoes so many of our urban
populations and causes enormous upheaval
mm-hmm or the scientifically literate
populace that is emerging with an
enthusiasm for scientific truth and
understanding the world by critical
thinking so it's the rate at which
people are learning versus the rate at
which people are dena are denied yeah
see here's the only problem with that
and I think you're absolutely right the
problem with that is as we continue down
this road which there is also a tipping
point where things become irreversible
and damage becomes extremely caddis
traffic you know not somewhat
catastrophic League catastrophic which
is the term that I'm trying to get the
violence you're over-exaggerating about
everything I'm with you you understand
me
so here's the problem those let's say we
reach the catastrophe those that believe
in denial will find another way to deny
it won't be because of climate change
and so when I say it's a close call I
mean we could lose I mean the humankind
could really be in huge trouble
not just the coastal populations in the
developing world but everybody could be
in trouble this is Startalk